bill walton joining us here Ben hey the
big man is here we were we were out
shooting hoops earlier and I thought
builder chair for a preschool yeah I
know I'm sorry about that sorry we
needed to get Phil Jackson's chair for
really and I usually bring my own but
I've been on the road for so long good
to see you Dan great to see you so it's
hot and all the guys and what's the guy
who got sunburned yesterday worse his
name huh Seaton Seaton I get sunburned
in the rain so just take it on and I do
want to say thanks to continental
because I ride Continentals on my bike
all right continental gator-skin 28
centimeters in the back the hard shell
yeah 25 centimeters in the front best
tire in the world just so smooth so
comfortable so safe thank more could you
ask for in life thank you Continental
thank you Dan Patrick - he's the Hall of
Famer two-time NBA champ two-time NCAA
champ two-time most outstanding player
three-time national college player of
the year I was lucky Dan you don't even
know that look I I had a great coach and
I had incredible teammates no no no and
that was the story of my entire career
you were great
I was lucky you were great you
understood the guy you saw greatness on
the court right there Dan Patrick I had
no idea you got Todd you didn't tell me
I've been chasing you around Todd for
have about 30 years at least yes and you
never told me that they had game he is
he pops staggering yeah why aren't you
in the NBA and you're so fit because I
wouldn't be able to do this and look
those guys over there
they have mouths to feed and if I didn't
do this I mean they'd be homeless there
so I thought I was coming to a radio
show and I pull up in the car today and
I thought I was at a dead show I mean
all the fans out here early some of us
sleeping in the park then and then this
big stage and people playing basketball
I mean this is very very cool
congratulations big-time way to gank you
but you walk onto the court and you
don't even say hello and I'm thinking
but bill is really casual here without
saying hello Emily
was you bill thought I was somebody
working on the set yeah shootin hoops I
thought he'd just done the lighting in
the rigging then and you're just out
waiting for the show to start yeah you
thought I didn't know that this was the
show yeah that's well I was trying to
put on a show before the show you did
and you rebounded for me how cool is
that cuz you know I love to rebound yes
man the end that's how I based my game
was on rebounding and I loved every part
of basketball I love the celebration my
game changed so much when I was 14
because I tore up my knee had the first
of 37 orthopedic operations at that
point but everything changed and I just
focused on rebounding and defense Bill
Russell was my favorite player ever on
and off the court but how would you play
today in your prime how would you I'm 63
years old I never play basketball thirty
year but a variety of 37 operations but
in in your prime we'd be fine in this
NBA but but you know it's not a big
man's it would be it would be if they
had better big men the game always
changes based on who the best players
are and right now Steph Curry's the best
player and I love Steph and I love
Dewar's I'm a warrior of the Golden
State and the way they play team
fast-break skill offense everything
passing and then you know that's that's
the dream come true and this guy Steph
klay Thompson Shaun Livingston draymond
Green
Andrew Bogut I mean the vision for a
team Dan is always the key and and that
was Jerry West you know it was a head
potential it had talent but when Jerry
came in and said okay now this is what
it can be because you look at all the
great teams in basketball they all have
a visionary guy who can see the future
and that is Jerry West and I had the
privilege when I was in college on the
Lakers when we were at the same time
there at UCLA there was will Elgin Jerry
Gayle Pat Riley Keith Erickson Bill
Sharman Casey Jones Chick Hearn Jack
Kent Cooke and they treated us like we
were on the Lakers they would come to
our games we would go to their games
we'd go to their practices they've
to our practices coach wouldn't bill
Sharman Casey Jones just like this it
was oh it's a radio show they were very
close it was it was just so
fantastically fun but that's all we knew
we just thought that's the way
everybody's life was engine playing
against will volleyball beach volleyball
never played basketball against will
will was the kindest person will it was
like magic will it was so friendly so
outgoing so kind if it will never said a
bad thing about anybody real with big
game would be coming up new star coming
up Roby's all this guys really good this
guy's really showing a lot of promise
I'd really an interesting and nice
fellow really looking forward to the
chance to play against this new guy
then Real Madrid gets 70 on him okay
yeah I'm but I don't think he liked the
competition of Kareem when Kareem came
in that all did changing they were
friends when wilt went then they were
growing up when Kareem was very young
yeah and then it kind of went the other
way because and that's fine because when
I played against all because we hated
them we hated each other and you know
cream and eye cream was like the
greatest player I ever played against by
far and here was a guy who you know
everybody's trying to get to be the best
and you're not friends with these guys
you know it's a different culture now
it's a different league and the league
I joined 42 years ago and it's so much
better now than it ever was and that's
because of David Stern who did who
brought the business acumen to a game
and he has built this incredible Empire
and since since the mid-80s when these
six forces and factors came together in
no particular order David Stern most
important man in the history of
basketball Phil Knight most important
man in the important in the history of
all sport Jerry Buss greatest owner ever
Michael Jordan David Falk Michaels agent
and then ESPN the ability to deliver
that message and how that from that
point everything has changed and what we
have everything is sponsored everything
is huge
everything is the best ever and and and
when you have a champion in any sport
today
the next day after the championship
there's always the article this is the
greatest team effort I want to address
we have the championship tonight North
Carolina they have more players the
challenge for Villanova is to have the
best player because in basketball when
you have the best player you've got the
greatest chance that that is always the
differentiator and that is why Steph
Curry is the leader of the band and the
best player in basketball on the best
team in basketball you'd like to join us
giving away tickets to tonight's title
game but somebody's got to make Drive
well it's a Steph Curry jumper that's a
difficult shot when I watch def play and
I love him when he's at three-quarter
court 75 feet from the basket I'm
yelling at the TV shoot it shoot it now
don't past it just get it up there he's
over good Nick because every time he
does miss draymond Green gets the
rebound and they have another chance a
Thompson yikes - and then Shaun
Livingston makes it and then leandro
barbosa who I thought was dead and then
he then he he comes back and he makes it
all these guys they just keep coming
he's Bill Walton in Houston providing
pregame halftime post game analysis for
Westwood ones final for coverage NCAA
radio network also check out Bill's New
York Times best-selling book back from
the dead which we'll get to coming up in
a moment who would have ever thought
little Billy that you wrote a book you
get back from the road the whole thing
did the whole audio book did all the
artwork with my great friend Mike Dubois
from the Grateful Dead world
Woodstock so he's got all this special
artwork in there we're making up some
fantastic posters I'll send you on I
love it and we're just having a great
time with it and it was tough it was
hard it simon and schuster man i mean a
great partner the best king of the
mountain in the publishing world they
said no a lot I thought I thought that
my parents and coach wouldn't restrict
oh my god these guys that's all they
said was no I will get to the book in a
moment okay the the poll question
McLovin for for Bill Walton is is what
if he had a better week's pay who would
win in a series the Bulls would sweep
the Warriors the Bulls would just beat
the Warriors or the Warriors would beat
the Bulls
well since I'm a volunteer it's a
there's nothing really at stake and so
I don't get involved in the ranking and
the rating of a historical different
teams I just enjoy them all it's like
going to a Grateful Dead concert
you know everybody said well I remember
back in 1975 at Cornell or wherever it
was I mean who that was yesterday
we're living I live in the moment I try
to learn from yesterday and I dream
about the future so then that one though
just to just to spec you every everybody
who's any good thinks they're the best
and anybody who's any good thinks that
their team is gonna win every single
game you play and are they coming for
you or for me you you I tell you oh my
gosh is there something you want to tell
me about oh those days at UCLA we had so
much we did everything we were right in
the mix College I loved where I was but
you guys were a rock star I mean oh yeah
now in do CLA but that was all we knew
because it was that way before we got
there it was that way after we left
every game sold out every game on
television Dick Enberg was our local
broadcaster and we had all the best
players and we had the best culture we
had the best fans we had the greatest
athletic director JD Morgan in the
history of NCAA sports we had the
Chancellor Charles Young who was there
for 29 years
we had ducky Drake who spent his life he
came there in 1923 and died on campus in
1988 65 years he was there every day and
these people damn they gave up their
lives so that our dreams could come true
it was pretty much like this show right
here I mean you have all these people
coming here trying to get tickets to the
show none of them can make a shot you
got the dancing girls with the
cheerleaders and and that was our world
eight miles away was the forum with
Wilton Jerry and Elgin and the Lakers
and
in the finals every year wilt was there
for five years they were in the finals
for the years UCLA later sent the 33
game winning streak we had an 88 game
winning streak at the time and it was
just perfect every day front page of the
paper every day all over the newsmen
it was just our lives and coach wooden
who was the ultimate teacher you know he
there was never a moment never a moment
where we thought he was in it for
himself there was never a moment where
easy where he would say no guys I can't
come today because I got something else
I've got to do I got to go give a speech
have to make a commercial never he was
always there on campus his door was
always open and the one thing that
always stood out to us was that he never
started practice with these words what
do you guys want to do today and he was
just so focused on making us better and
he was totally concerned with who we
were becoming as young adults could he
have coached in the NBA he didn't want
to he loved college he loved teaching he
he could have done
he was like Kareem Wilton Shaq and that
they could he could have done anything
that he wanted to do and he had so many
different interests and I was mad sad
and disappointed when he retired at 65
in 1975 after the 10th championship in
12 years should have been 12 and 12 but
the but you know because I thought that
you know he was leaving so much on the
table I did not realize that his life
was just beginning although his wife
died 10 years later and then he spent 25
years without his beloved nil and you
know he he loved that lady and he an old
boy she did not like me
can you imagine did you get can you
imagine what she used to say to him when
I got arrested when I was you know you
know against Nixon and all this stuff in
Vietnam and all my gosh
that she would look at me and just scowl
wow he was he was always so kind he was
always so generous and he was incredibly
patient we got a freeway going by here
we got a war zone out here downtown
interestin God I told these guys the
story of when we were at NBA
entertainment right and I gave you a
ride in my Jetta and we were listening
wonder I have a
that's fine no bill is in the front seat
and you're my knees like this yeah
you're like that and then bills like my
head oh I know isn't it what you want to
know what kind of to like you forget
this a radio yeah well it's TV shows TV
show - yeah yeah see the oh no I don't
deal for cameras yeah I got it
this is a microphone that is or so I was
telling these guys you want to know what
kind of tunes I had and I said I had
Dillon no great and I remember this ride
so I think you were playing the chimes
of freedom because I love the chimes of
freedom but I love everything Bob Dylan
and he's coming back on tour this summer
the west coast you being Eugene Berkeley
Santa Barbara San Diego two nights at
Humphreys and then closing it out on the
Shrine Auditorium before heading for Red
Rocks and we'll be at all of them you
weren't you weren't a very good singer
back then bill I'm an excellent singer
and a tremendous dancer just give him a
sample a little Dylan as you were a time
in the car in the Jetta and Mar between
Sundowns finish and Midnight's broken
toll we ducked inside the doorway
Thunder crashing yes told him for the
Warriors holding for the luckless the
abandoned enforce a tolling for the
outcasts burning constantly a stake
striking for the gentle striking for the
kind striking for the guardians and
protectors of the mind and for every
uptight hung-up person in this whole
wide universe we gaze upon those chimes
of freedom flashing here we go well done
well done but if you want to if you want
to hear a song missing the Thea Gilmore
sing Bob Dylan's all remember you it'll
just bring the tears to your eyes oh my
gosh is that the chimes of freedom
Amnesty International release that he
did donated all the money to Amnesty
International and it was absolutely
incredible Thea Gilmore but all the
performances spectacular but Thea
Gilmore just tug at your heartstrings
Dan the book is back from the dead and
he's Bill Walton he'll be part of the
coverage tonight who you oh you don't
pick right I I don't have a stake so I
always root for the underdog North
Carolina is the favorite yeah they've
got more they've got big guys they got
little guys they've got everything but
Villanova
the way they played what I like about
both teams they're not gimmick teams but
this is substance you know I'm not a
gimmick guy I'm not one of these guys
are like the double-team trap being in
all kinds of strategy
give me players players make plays plays
don't make players the job with the
coach and this was where Wooden was that
his best wooden Lenny Ramsay Red
Auerbach all the great coaches that I
played for denny crum who was with last
night at the hall of fame dinner and
their job is to make you a great player
and that's what coaches do and then
build the team around a great player and
then when the game starts just I
remember would this guy wouldn't after
he told us how to put our shoes and
socks on right and he went throughout
that whole thing we're out there running
around up and down the court playing and
he stops practice because he never
stopped practice but at the very
beginning he stopped the practice and he
looked at everybody and he said you know
we're UCLA we're the fast-break team
we're the full-court press we are
offense we are relentless attack on a
constant basis and he said in the open
court anybody can do anything you want
nobody will ever say a word to you just
attack and go to the basket pull up and
shoot jumpers cuz our game is speed
quickness and offense and then he turned
deadly serious and he looked at
everybody he said but if the other team
is back defensively and dug in it's a
setup plate everybody's holding their
breath and he goes if Bill Walton and
Jamal wilt don't get the ball every
single time the rest of you guys are
coming out and all the guys Greg Larry
and Henry their faces just dropped you
know Jamal and I go yeah this is very
nice
I can buy into this team concept it's
always great to see you have fun tonight
the book is in its New York Times
best-selling book back from the dead
he's Bill Walton I'm the luckiest guy in
the world new one back to the dead you
are I'm back to Dan Patton who would
have ever thought oh I'll pick you up in
my Jeddah empanada
I had my spine fused the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience
you